hello everyone my name is Wray Co arts
I'm especially happy to be here today
not only because I was in prison for
eight and a half years but also because
I'm here representing the last mile my
life dramatically changed when I made a
commitment to my family and myself to
maximize my time in prison so that I can
become a productive member of society
after my release during my time of
incarceration
I received an Associate of Arts degree
from Patton University
I read numerous books and prepared
myself mentally for the challenges that
I was facing a free world and the last
mile was the final step towards freedom
for me I I the program provided
knowledge and confidence that would
allow me to be where I am today I left
San Quentin March 12 and today I work in
San Francisco I rally dot org on the
first day of last mile each participant
must sign a pledge of agreement this
pledge extends beyond the length of the
program it is a lifetime commitment to
ourselves our family and our brothers
and to everyone that we meet this is the
last mile over that we pledged I pledge
to maintain a high level of respect and
integrity as a member of the last mile I
will uphold my commitment in practice
and in spirit to help the program
advance authentic learning trust and
leadership I will not participate in
activities that are detrimental to my
position or activities that will
negatively reflect the last mile program
I will encourage my fellow members of
the last mouths to lead by positive
example inside the institution and
outside in a free world I realized that
this is a commitment that will endure
for a lifetime but if broken it will
result in an immediate dismissal from
the program I make this place I've made
this pledge in the spirit of honor
dedication and trust as I look toward my
future I'm committed to become
successful professionally and personally
and to help other last-mile graduates
after they are released to society this
is my chance to shine and rebuild my
personal brand the last mile is our
fraternity and this is my commitment
thank you Ray as a testament to the
power of the program he trusted in the
program and he believed in the program
we guarantee that every graduate of the
last mile after they served their time
it's a paid internship they work hard
for that this is the first step to a
successful future many startups begin
with a simple idea that's inspired
buying enlightened moments my
enlightened moment for the last mile
came three years ago I was invited to
San Quinn to speak to a group of men
about business and entrepreneurship I
had never been in prison before that
first day when I first arrived I was
ushered through a series of gates until
I arrived at the courtyard at the center
of the prison on my left the adjustment
Center which houses all death row
inmates in California and some of the
most notorious criminals in California
on my right the Catholic chapel which
was surrounded by a well manicured
garden I was as they say at San Quentin
at the gate between heaven and hell I
was led down a paved road past the guard
towers into the lower yard
where hundreds of men dressed in blue
were exercising milling around or
playing checkers at that point I was
questioning my decision to come to sin
but I was led into a small classroom
where I was supposed to speak about 50
men NASA began to spoke speak I noticed
how they were fixated on every word
there was no distraction there's no
cellphones in prison after my talk and
shot in the air and my 30-minute talk to
you about a two-hour session and I was
struck by their interest their
preparation and their commitment to
create a better life after they served
their time so I left San Quentin that
night really excited I was going to tell
Beverly this Tina said we run a kick
accelerator called kick labs in San
Francisco we work with young
entrepreneurs every day why not here at
night he was so energized he had that
look in his eyes that he gets when he
has extreme focus and intention and he
started telling me about his experience
and how surprised he was at the level of
interest and understanding of business
that the men portrayed were in the
audience for his speech so then he
starts pitching me on the idea his new
startup is going to be the last mile we
came became the last mile and we were
going to have a startup program inside
San Quentin well I am NOT an easy sell
and my first reaction was why would I
want to spend my free time because I
have so little of it anyway why would I
want to spend my free time working with
prisoners but he had that passion and he
actually asked me not to make any
judgments about something I knew very
little about so reluctantly I committed
to do research about incarceration and
also to go and visit the men to
experience firsthand what he was so
passionate about so first was my
research well I wanted to find out about
more more about the issues facing the
prison system in California today and
what I learned from my research made me
realize that even a small-scale effort
could make a difference so here's some
of the learnings in California we spend
more for prisons than higher education
the average cost per prisoner to
taxpayers $45,000 the rate of recidivism
exceeds 60% so by the time many men are
released from San Quentin as taxpayers
we've already invested nearly 1 million
dollars of their incarceration but
without rehabilitation many of them will
return that's a bad investment if we
could reduce recidivism by just 5%
billions of dollars could be saved in
the next 10 years alone but without
rehabilitation these problems will
persist so if that wasn't convincing
enough for me to get involved I went to
San Quentin
so I could meet the men many of whom
later became the founding members of the
last mile and it was then that I
realized why Chris was so passionate
about this program
these men were not bad people they're
people who made bad decisions and many
of them decades ago I saw hope in their
eyes they are determined to succeed and
to right they're wrong and to give back
to their communities and make their
families proud so I agreed I was on
board
I joined Chris as co-founder of the last
mile and we created this program as our
social cause
from that point on our goal is to help
these men turn their dreams into reality
and begin to pave the road to success so
we started the program but we have to
have as you you know learn and and talk
about startups what are our KPIs how do
we judge the success of this group and
first the first thing that we had to
understand and appreciate was does it
resonate with the men in prison is this
something they want to learn and can
they really absorb the applications that
we're presenting to them because they
have no internet access they have no
access to technology and will the
correctional system adopt but we're
trying to do and be open enough to
understand what we're trying to
accomplish we didn't ask to do a program
we asked to do a program that we thought
would be disruptive and beneficial and
create a pipeline for people like Ray to
have a better life that meant that we
were doing things that they weren't used
to one of the things that we asked to do
was allow the men to participate in
social media
we wanted them to to have a voice to get
a response but you all of us take take
for granted today these men and never
experienced we also wanted them to
really understand how to build a
business plan and how to get the
confidence that they can enter a job
either create their own or enter a job
and feel confident like they belong so
when we started to see things that
really resonated and get comments from
the men that really were profound one of
the men in our program Larry Houston
said and that door closes to our class
for a two-hour session I forget that I
mean they also have to do things that
again are difficult for us to do but
even more difficult for them because
many of them have never done this
process they've never gone through a
collaborative environment and maybe
never presented anyone before in our
first session we had a man named Eric
Phillips who the first session at a
difficult time stringing two sentences
together and he went on and struggled
for the first month so many of you may
not be old old enough to remember the
movie but you remember my fair lady
Henry Higgins is teaching how to go from
a cockney accent to a proper British
accent so that night I walked in class
singing the rain in Spain stays mainly
in the plain they thought it was out of
my mind but we had Phil start to sing
his presentation and when it came to
demo date it was flawless and some of
the people that same claim came up to me
and said either Phil has been
reincarnated or he has a twin brother
but that's a type of response that we
needed to see that really resonated the
second one was engagement
Beverly and I can do this ourselves to
some degree but we really need
volunteers and people on the outside to
bring their expertise in as well so as
we would in business we try to those key
influencers and market that would really
help us to teach but also to share the
message so we invited entrepreneurs and
some from our portfolio and some from
the outside and we also have a reading
curriculum and the first author we
invited him was Guy Kawasaki I came in
not only did he come in he donated the
books and he was phenomenal he said it
was this most captured audience who's
ever in front of so guys been here
before so you can appreciate his sense
of humor but from then we got Brian
solace who many of you know is well
known in the social media area for his
writings jon hamm who wrote a book on
leadership Andy Smith and Stanford's own
professor Jennifer rocker who wrote
Dragonfly effect as well participated so
that type of participation is great
business leaders MC Hammer you saw in
the video of well-known VC Josh problem
and some of the up-and-coming the
entrepreneurs in the valley Brian Wong
who was in the 30 under 30 of the Forbes
list Patrick Collison who has a company
called stripe data they all came in and
donated their time then we realized that
this is a program that we could scale
with the right type of involvement and
and people volunteering
the third and most important part was
are we gonna get businesses people to
support people like Bray after they
graduate and after they serve their time
that means that businesses have to step
out to something that they're not
necessarily comfortable with but believe
it or not we have many businesses now
that have reached out dozens they will
participate Sachi doctor from Raley is
here with us today and rally was one of
the first companies to raise our hand
and said open this we we actually have
one of the guys who was in in the video
pinata Liao who actually closed the
video already has a job waiting for him
and he's still incarcerated he was that
impressive that Duncan Logan from
Rockets pay said I'm gonna sign this guy
today because I know he's gonna have
multiple offers what we're trying to do
really a show that these men have skills
and opportunities that they can actually
add value I was with the CEO of rally
yesterday Tom Cirrus and he said he said
to me what's the deal with great and I
looked him like he said he's smiling
every day he's infectious with his
enthusiasm he's added value already to
our company so this is not a one-way
street it's a mutual benefit which is
really makes us feel great that we can
start adding that value so those are our
KPIs that's what we're looking at doing
as we start expanding and our expansion
has started really in September we will
be expanding our program to Folsom
Prison and we'll be expanding to LA
County and also University of Michigan
outside universe efficient and the
attacks and the coolest part of that is
that we're not only expanding the last
mile but we're taking that curriculum to
a very functional area we're actually
teaching a Python programming starting
in the women's prison in Folsom so not
only are we teaching entrepreneur tip
over
also teaching functional job
applications our biggest challenge is
teaching the men how the digital world
has changed over the last decade
realizing that not a single one of them
has been on the internet used a
smartphone or a mobile app or as the CEO
of Twitter Dick Costolo so aptly says
they don't have the Internet in their
pants like let's say you do so they read
books by digital media and business
experts and they interact with guest
speakers from startup companies from
technology companies and they listen and
learn from our experience until they get
a chance on the outside to experience it
firsthand
they also tweet blog and answer
questions on poro which is amazing
because there's no internet access in
prison so they actually have to hand
write or type their content it's not
real-time it's then taken out by our
volunteers and uploaded to the net and
it's actually a requirement of the
program that the men tweet on a daily
basis they answer at least one question
on Quora every week and create a blog
post and those blog posts are posted on
our site last mile org but they're also
distributed through other media networks
and media sites like the Huffington Post
or the daily love where we actually have
a weekly feature I'm also on the
Atlantic Monthly and even the Wall
Street Journal just to name a few so
social media plays a big role in our
curriculum even though they're not on
the Internet in fact just recently Chris
and I returned from New York City we
were on stage at the time Center to
accept an award for one of our founding
members Crispino Kenyatta layout who was
also featured in the video he received
the shorty award for the poor answer of
the year which is amazing because he was
selected from thousands of questions he
won the award and I was able to go into
San Quentin
before we left for New York to shoot a
video of him accepting the award his
acceptance speech was created inside San
Quentin and then shown on a huge screen
in New York City and broadcast to
thousands of people and this is a way
for him to have a voice and be a person
not a prisoner it was really a great
honor and just an amazing experience and
we're very proud of all of our graduates
for their accomplishments so they learn
about social media they learn about
business they listen to entrepreneurs
they listen to guest speakers they read
these books and finally what they do for
their final project is they need to
conceive of a business idea and then
create a plan and each one must include
the technology component and a social
cause and in fact we teach them to
create a business plan utilizing the
same business model canvas that's taught
at the University of Michigan Ross
Business School so we have people who
come in to the sessions they practice
their pitch they start with a one-minute
elevator pitch where they get their
whole concept down and we have people
from Forrester Research and some of the
venture firms and entrepreneurs and
volunteers who they go the state
warriors I mean a whole spectrum not
just technology who come in and listen
to their pitches in particular and they
learn what it means to pivot and they
learn what it means to actually change
your message because no one understands
what you're trying to convey or you're
not conveying exactly exactly what you
had intended to do once they get their
pitch down they then expanded to a five
minute presentation with a PowerPoint
show and they present those to a live
audience of invited guests
and fellow inmates so we've already had
two graduating classes there have been
two demo days which we consider to be a
great success and here is the logos of
just some of the companies that have
been created by the members of the last
mile program we even had first lady of
California and brown in the audience our
first demo day and I'll say without
exception when people leave they are so
inspired and impressed by what they've
seen some have even commented that the
pitches are better than those they've
seen at demo days in Silicon Valley and
we're very very proud of that so at
first glance the the last mile appears
to be a program that teaches business
skills entrepreneurship presentation
skills and social media what's happening
in the world of business today so that
when the men leave prison don't have it
will be in the dark ages I'll understand
what's happening in the world have the
ability to create their own good fortune
but it's really a lot more than that
because as you know collaborative and
creative learning environments just
austere creativity and great ideas and
great things can happen one of the
things we believe very strongly in is
for the last mile we teach them all that
so many life lessons will help them be
successful so we needed social proof I
needed social proof when I started as
saying if we teach these men these
skills could they actually be successful
so one of my inspirations is Dave Dahl
and some of you may actually buy his
bread
yes great breath so dave is a really
interesting story and he's he's kind of
put me over the edge saying I think this
will work
Dave was incarcerated off and on for 15
years it's a meth addict it's suicidal
he didn't get serious about education
till his last 18 months when he got out
he didn't have anything but desire to
actually have been for the for the last
time sort of makes some of the helmet
still and his family had a small bakery
and he went to his brother who was
running the bakery and said I wanted to
be part of the baby I said no but you
can go do your own thing in the corner
so Dave did his own thing made his own
recipes and went to the same farmers
markets that his family's bakery well he
started out selling the family baked and
Dave's business started to grow this
year Dave will do about a hundred
million in sales and almost every
weekend Dave speaking to school youth
group for some sort of social Dave's
been in sync went with us several times
and he is constantly an inspiration for
me affect me says hello to you today he
was actually going to come here for this
you couldn't do it because of another
altercation I get a lot of questions and
we get a lot of questions about you know
these guys do these business plans
anything actually gonna wish so James
Houston is a graduate from last year he
has been incarcerated for 18 years it's
from Richard and James has had an
impeccable record inside he is one of
the most respected guys at Stanford and
he's actually started a program called
the Pittsburgh project which is helping
guys as they get out when they go back
home he's still in arts me
his plan that he developed inside that's
called teen tech huh
and T tech hub is an after-school
program it's 9 to 14 years old Richmond
where they can learn about computers he
presented his pitch at our demo day and
in the audience was a guy named Eric
poor Eric also grew up but Eric became
an investment thing and Eric is it's
about six three big husky black guy and
he's sitting in the audience he's
sitting me Krista looked Brown and that
was American fist supposed to be a
little poncho and you're right because
what James is presenting is what I
wanted to do back so in September were
actually launching teen tech hub we have
a location James comes back home in June
and it's the first one of many that we
want new process early but it just shows
that that dream that he had the dream
dirt Eric met come together to create
something like barely said that you know
not only are they creating business
plans but each one of those plan has to
have the social cost so we have Gordo so
who is sitting in the audience here is a
mm both reg Julia came to us two months
after serving over seven years and he
actually went through the last mile
program on the outside
worked extremely hard and he we got the
approval for him to go back into
segments and present at demo day so
think about going back into 43 odd
experience but he was phenomenal in his
presentation and he now is independent
as his own consulting business where he
does small websites per SM B's his learn
WordPress and Drupal and he has more
customers and he knows but part of what
julia has done is social causes create
something called collaborative etiquette
and this is basically the LinkedIn for
incarcerated so that men now can have a
place where you can find out about that
either before after they're released
it's a way for them to communicate with
each other after their release and also
for businesses to step up and
participate and talk to each other find
out what works what doesn't
is the graduates from both classes and
I'll close with a little story about
someone named David bro David Munroe
grew up in Stockton
and he was in a family of drugs and
battery and he was in a gang a gang was
his family and David killed a rival gang
member but he was 15 years old he was
given a life sentence for David every
day was survivable not knowing whether
he was going to be killed
we're happy for David Stockton was his
Afghanistan David served 16 years and
he's ready to give back to society he
goes in front of the parole board next
year and will be there with thank you
very much
this was life in prison there's not a
lot of tasks that you have to do one of
the things that I have a challenge with
being free is I have several tasks that
I need to complete during the day like
15 tasks at least every day but in
prison yeah like for TAS you get up in
the morning you go to Chow you go to
work you come back you go to Chow again
or count time in between that go back to
Chow then you go to school if you go to
school or study or play your games board
games then it's count time and then
that's it that's your day but here you
know I'm responding to emails texting
I'm working on different projects so the
difference between prison and being free
is pretty big as far as what your day
looks like and also like commuting you
don't commute to work right walk up a
pathway it takes you about two or three
minutes to get there and in here you
know I bought in from Dublin the San
Francisco I was like an hour commute so
so it's a big difference an interesting
difference there so I'm curious in
starting this program you made it seem
so simple okay
Beverly Chris you made it seem like he
came up with his idea and Austin got
hatched I mean what were the challenges
to get this going
well first I was convinced Beverly you
know the the biggest challenge is that
we all are used to this idea of
disruption that's that's
you know the system so to speak is very
allergic food disruption so when I
walked when I went to Sacramento first
time and I said disrupt and hack they
they felt like I assured him out of the
office so it's this legacy sort of
process that doesn't allow for change so
as I said before you know this wasn't
gonna be a program just another reentry
program this one it was going to be a
blue reentry program that that had
results that we were doing different
that everyone here could participate in
by reading or respond no we were at
Korra earlier today speaking with epic
company and fora has been a great
opportunity for the men to express
themselves but even more so for people
to comment back that was really
difficult for Department of Corrections
to deal you know when we started we have
to started we had to start tweeting
first they had to read every tweet they
realized that's a lot of work then they
said you will give it to you but just
don't screw up and then we started doing
a little blogging and got on Quora now
we do this pass or every week there's
tons of content for produce but I think
that was the biggest challenge us
getting the system to understand what's
right so there are some other challenges
I would say number one is just getting
in so you would think it'd be really
easy to get in that is gonna get out but
just the process of going through all
the guards stands and getting your
credentials and finally make its class
started at 6:15 you we would leave and
get to the first card stand about 30
minutes prior and just the frustration
of the lockdowns
so we have a specific agenda we have our
curriculum we have our program we have
our demo day and all the activities that
we need to do to prepare for demo day
but you show up at the gate and we can't
get in because there's a lockdown a
lockdown because it was fight lockdown
because there was a virus and lockdown
because there
doing some kind of inoculation so it's
very unpredictable what you couldn't
actually enroll everyone in our program
and expect to have a smooth smelling me
then the other challenge was not similar
to my initial response and in trying to
describe what we're doing to people and
not rally their support I thought was
going to be very difficult I thought
that we would have naysayers and people
who say why are you spending your time
and energy doing that when there's so
many other places the world with your
energy but honestly it's place that
deserves attention is definitely
becoming very much in the spotlight
because of our tremendous deficit where
are we spending our money if we could
help to reduce the amount of money we're
spending and have that excess capital to
invest in our children and our education
so that they don't go that route Rachel
why did you choose to participate I mean
this was sort of something it sounds
like you didn't really know much about
before you started what was it that
attracted you to this type of program
living in prison oh well I learned at a
program through a friend of mine but
prior to hearing about glass mouth like
it was the first class graduate and I
think September 2012 yeah and I had a
like six months to go if I was going to
be released but I had studied business
books and read financial books and
magazines because I really thought that
I would no one would hire me I was going
to have to become self-employed Greymon
company so I I studied for eight years
preparing to make a life for myself I
wanted to create my own company and I
attended I was invited to attend demo
day and I'm sitting there and I watching
some guys that was wearing blue just
like me present these
wonderful and very viable businesses and
I'm like I need to be in that program
you know so I submitted my application
and I was selected participate has
demand for the program increased since
you've gone through now two classes we I
mentioned the programs that we're
expanding to when we started it it was
truly an experiment but we we actually
have a group in Canada that's already
created a website like not even ready so
that last mile is coming to Canada like
it or not
so yeah it's really struck the board I
think because the people that come in
you know we've had over 50 volunteers
come in over the last two sessions and
they become evangelists and basically we
just say come in and give us two hours
when I ask for money to spend two hours
if your opinion doesn't change in those
two hours never come back there's been
one person that's come out after a
session saying this is amazing I'm
coming back and telling her so it's been
that virality that has really expanded
and then now we're starting to get
correctional facilities on
so there's definitely demand and I
really believe that the coding Bricklin
has got it aside from the Bur ality on
the outside it's also about the morality
on the inside because word spreads
quickly not a lot of secrets inside
there's malls and when we first started
we didn't know any of the population so
we had to rely upon other trusted people
to make recommendations for our counting
class and it was so we had a smaller
class to start and then of course once
we had our demo day and had an
instructional session about what the
program was and then had a graduate who
became successful people started
believing in trusting us and we I talked
about the fact that we have business
books as part of the curriculum and it
just so happens that guy Kawasaki's book
and I think jon Hamm's book were both
read
and we take the jackets off we they have
hardcover books which is an exception to
the rule I supposed to have hard covered
books and they all were carrying around
these read books and the the founding
members of the program so other inmates
what's this all about
and we like the red book Rowan but it
became aspirational in inside especially
after our first demo day too
part of it in order in the first class
or the coding which won't even start
into the fall we already have it's
really helped people lift they're kind
of the level of who they are and their
character inside because if you have any
interactions we wouldn't I want to ask
one more question before I open up to
the audience what sort of support do
people get once they leave obviously
this sounds like an incredible program
when you're actually in prison and you
have all these mentors coming in and all
the support I mean when you leave what
sort of programs are there to help you
get to the next step so so what I'm
doing right now I'm interning that rally
but I'm also using their platform to
raise money for other last-mile
graduates many of the graduates will be
released with $200 and little support
financial support so I would like to
raise funds to help them purchase phones
computers help with transportation
clothing and just will I give them that
that need meet that need that they'll
have when they first get out support
their first 60 days I I've been out for
too much never received any other income
but my family was fortunate to provide
to support that I may have a successful
transition so I would like to get other
graduates the same opportunity their bed
is you know come through the program so
I would like to help now so we were
doing this but is does the program have
any yeah well we're in the process of
creating or 501c3 now because we did
self-supportive a program a part of what
we want to do is because really like Ray
said it's that first 90 120 days the the
internship program that we have is 120
days so they have immediately a place to
go and get something done but we want to
want to put a scholarship program on top
of that so they can buy so that's so two
things first is we have an internship
program however the applicants must
interview apply and be accepted by the
employer it's not an instant job so you
still need to do a lot of work to become
employed great did that we went through
a rigorous interview process great let's
he's there at rally and he actually
created his own rally campaign so now
not only is he helped going to help
future graduates of the program but he
truly understands the platform and can
help others accomplish what they would
like to do to for their own costs and
then the last thing sorry I want to say
is that as you heard in the pledge
everybody who is a participant in our
program is a participant for life and so
it was so hard for me to watch
Tullio helping ray to understand his
computer and searching and showing him
keysight's and just kind of being his
tutor which is a way to pay it forward
and so those are the type of things we
do so there's a cultural getting back
and helping the others who are going to
be followed behind you great so let's
open up for questions we've got the
first one here so the question is how do
you select the people to participate in
the program they have to either graduate
from Patton University which is two-year
program or be close to graduation there
are other programs there that are more
self-help that we want them to go
through more of a self realization they
have to go through a variety of
interviews you write some writing
exercises they have to be recommended by
someone who's currently in the program
and they have to be approved by the
prison administration so it's yeah yes
exactly so having a sponsor a fantastic
way to really address recidivism which
is or area performance while ago there
really needs a vision of your club to
vary what you're doing with legislation
you know Governor Brown is very
supportive but we're making a conscious
effort to do that do this privately so
all of our funds and support will become
privately you know I think when we went
to Sacramento the first time we finished
the meeting with Matt kata was the
Secretary of Prisons at the time I think
he was waiting for us to have her hand
out and my hand was this instead of this
and it made a big difference right so we
can get a lot further by doing it
outside of that and we and we really
want to show that you can marry private
public effectively without taking public
funds so that's really been our actually
repeat the question how could you do
that
yeah what was a question that received
the shortywood it was what is the
yeah yeah so so yeah Kenyatta answered
question and the question was what is
the first day of a five plus year
sentence for those of you who don't know
what a shorty award is it's like an
Academy Award for social media it's a
pretty big deal
I'll go check it out how big is a class
what's the Graduate yeah the class the
maximum for last mile will be twelfth
and in coding it's twenty seven it's
it's been about 80 percent we've some
guys you know just haven't stepped up so
some have have not completed the program
that's been about 80 percent and frankly
our goal is to have a zero recidivism
rate for all graduates that's what we
strive for to your point no and we have
small numbers but I think just like Dave
doll was a beacon of hope for so many
people and it was inspiration to me big
guys like Ray out here he's gonna be an
inspiration doesn't take many to create
that book that's we did have space
constraints to begin with but recently
we've been very fortunate to have had a
classroom actually built for us and I
think it was partially because of the
coding curriculum and the reason our
coding curriculum is a class of 27 is
because there's very strict requirements
about how many men can be together
without a guard being present even
though we are there as certified green
card holders so we can be alone in the
classroom but not only do we have the
participants and the current program in
the room but the graduates of each other
class continue to participate because we
have different guest speakers we have
different books we have different
curriculum and they could lead sessions
for the current class and are able to
interact and actually act as mentors so
when we're in the process of creating
our PowerPoint presentations and our
pitches was so cool to watch the
graduates critiquing the current in
current participants in their pitch
and up to to guide them to a successful
presentation just said a minute ago
because it sparked a big question that I
think probably a lot of people have you
said there's a certain number of men
that can be in the room without a guard
was there ever a moment that you felt
unsafe was this ever a situation where
you felt what am I doing here oh well
there's yeah
do we feel in danger well I think when
you walk into San Quentin there's a big
sign that basically says after you pass
this sign you're on your own there is no
hostage policy right so San Qin is
unusual because because of our clearance
we basically have full access and we're
not escorted around yeah I think it's a
bit daunting I mean I've been to
different prisons when you go to Folsom
it's level three it's a little bit
stranger because you know there it's a
little more dangerous I guess maybe you
can talk about the different levels of
different prisons San Quentin is is
unusual it has death row in level two
level two is basically guys get to go in
the yard be a little more free
participating classes but I have to say
though that now we've been there I've
been there for three years they all know
us and when I walk across the yard at
night at segments I feel more
comfortable than I would walking at
night in sentences as a woman walking
through the yard it's a little daunting
when I am there by myself but I been
very fortunate to have my security
device with me at all times and this is
the security vice that they recommend
that we carry it's just a whistle and so
I guess when if I were to blow this
whistle the rule is that everybody would
have to in the yard
would take a knee so that if there is
any confrontation the guards but that's
told you looks what's going on but this
is my security only on stage at Michigan
that's serious if they hear that they
draw the right oh I'll decide today from
from a prisoner's perspective Chris and
Beverly are very valuable to the
Institute's and there's a lot of
prisoners who would really probably take
accident if something was to happen to
them because they have so much value
inmates wouldn't let anything happen
it's good to Crescent Beverly I mean no
one no one said but yeah yeah I mean in
your plans to scale for example to other
prisons how do you plan on I guess
picking framework were distributing the
personal touch so I want to repeat this
the question is you seem to have a
secret sauce there's something special
about your relationship how can this
scale how do you scale this in other
places since you certainly can't be
everywhere at once no I understand
you're saying but I don't necessarily
agree I think that there's such a strong
desire for them to learn and absorb and
you know be be successful it's not about
me it's not about everything really it's
about the program it's about this
camaraderie I mean frankly we bring in
all these people we don't say much
during those sessions on bring people in
we also have a film crew another things
me a long time to get through but we
have a film crew that comes in twice a
month and they film what we're doing and
we're rehearsing that content so that we
can send it to other prison we're
actually in the process of
creating a curriculum sheet for every
day of the program and part of this is
pure led as well but for certain parts
of that we'll have video that they can
play so it's almost franchising in the
sense so I really believe that the year
or two from now they won't even know who
we are it's the last mile it's it's
really being you know promoted in any
place it's really not about something
really important in terms of scale as
Tina knows one of the biggest
innovations that higher education has
moved massively open online courses
where instead of having two hundred
people taking the class based on them
you can have ten thousand or forty eight
dollars or whatever and I was thinking
that the if you're capturing it usually
you're gonna have massively closed
online right to where you gotta go
within a firewall but you can digitize
the stuff and really think of every
prison in the world it seems to me yeah
VBR we can play DVDs so yeah it's it's a
good way to scale yes what what I had
done in so there are people in Latin
America and China and stuff want to know
how to do what we do we show them a
digital courts what we do and then local
people say we're gonna localize this to
probably what makes a Pacific your and
that that's the best of look where
you've got a the passion on the ground I
can you but content I can leverage so
they don't have to shoot okay rolling
out in Canada and also LA is of course a
lot easier for us because we're close by
and we already have relationships with a
lot of businesses there and people who
want to come in and teach the program
but that's exactly what our goal is is
to create these modules that can be used
anywhere can I can I move on thanks
I have a question here so the question
is is this all volunteers who come in to
participate but the one thing that we're
hiring our coordinators is it just
scheduling and all that we really
believe that it's it's most effective by
a volunteer basis because people are
very passionate so yeah I think we'll
continue that I mean we're gonna have a
people and paid staff for the most part
it's gonna be two things when it's going
to be volunteer based and at least 30
percent of program will be purely be led
by the guys it's a different question
that we can learn from and they have a
different experience it is something
that we should put so the question is
what can we learn sitting here at
Stanford and outside a prison what can
we learn from the things that you teach
inside a prison you know we've actually
adopted some of the things that we've
we've developed inside of when we work
with young entrepreneurs and keep labs
part of what we do we get them pretty
early so they have to learn how to not
only money but and it's amazing how bad
they are so we actually make these guys
condense it they're pitching for one
minute my show of hands how many of you
have witnessed either a parent a child a
friend or maybe your spouse struggle
with obesity you don't have to raise
your hand for this one but think about
it
did you ever feel helpless in their
struggle if you have they're not alone
many people who have lived in a
low-income community like I have what
obesity rate is above 50% have
experienced the same feeling of
helplessness that's why today I'm doing
something about it
good evening my name is Horatio Hart and
I'm the founder of healthy hearts
Institute the coop that would bring
health and fitness back into our
neighborhoods HHI will turn empty lots
into Gardens and transform neighborhoods
of food deserts and to green nutritional
assistance we will turn abandoned
buildings and to LEED certified fitness
centers and provide our members safe
places to exercise our goal is to get us
back to the good old days when the
community was ripe with nutritional
foods kids were outside running the
plant and obesity rate was below 17
percent so join the healthy hearts
Institute and let us empower the beat of
your heart thank you
that's one last question we have a lot
of really passionate people here who are
really motivated to have a positive
impact on the world how can they get
involved I mean how can I get involved
thank you for asking that we have a
slide for that like everybody ask your
followers and share our message share
our message with all your friends in the
world watch our videos sorry about the
mic or about you can watch our TED talk
you can watch our demo days watch the
men watch what they do spread the word
volunteer so what would that look like
some of the real needs we have are a
people to come to our sessions people to
come to our sessions and to talk to the
men share your experiences reveal the
real need we have higher up graduate one
of your startup which would be great
also our social media is snacks in our
Joe as our program grows and grows and
grows we always have a need for people
to help us with input and to manage the
profiles that they need a specific
program or potentially even one of our
participants and come to our demo day we
just require certification in advance
and clearance but please join us for a
demo day and experience first hand what
rages did was his one-minute fish but he
actually presented for five minutes
with a powerful PowerPoint logos etc the
fact that he meaning that versus
one-minute fish the way he does and
percentage what he did is just
outstanding when he first started the
program I never would have believed that
he could get up and see and present like
that it's just
so come and witness it firsthand that I
think you could do to help is also
support my rally at rally dot org slash
pay them the world to success and make a
pledge give other guys opportunities
that I had join me in thanking these
fabulous guests today
you